they are the pride of Central Florida
and Seattle Washington and points all
over planet Earth because their story is
amazing their brotherhood and friendship
is inseparable as the book that they
have written is letting everybody know
about the book is called inseparable the
teammates from the Seattle Seahawks the
brothers Griffin Shaquille and Shekinah
Griffin right here on the Rich Eisen
show good to see you guys how was she
killed how was the ESPYs last night I
was that it was fun it was fun the heat
wasn't too bad
never been there last year was it was
pretty hot but besides that the red
carpet was fine and man we've seen some
amazing people I panned out that was the
best part get a chance to meet so many
great people and drop some names drops
times
what are you done I forgot um who was
the first one I came from your name my
brother came do you remember without my
Pete would you meet we met so many
people it was a little world went for us
I mean not only just they meet all the
celebrities it's kind of hard when you
know you got three people want to take
pictures of you anyone hey pictures of
people is like mm-hmm
now you don't want to be that person you
don't want to be that guy sometimes so
you know I did took mental pictures you
took mental pictures you know I'm always
remember I said we never got to the
point was like hey can I take a picture
sure we never had an experience but I
felt that last night uh-huh and then I
couldn't get it out you couldn't know
one day I'm just gonna be like I need a
picture just keep asking so the u.s.
women's soccer team combined I wanted
picture bat
you know my agent like just say so much
like next time it did he say can you get
a picture they say we gotta go I said I
see no but it's different your agent
does it yeah and if you Shaquille
Griffin does it it's a totally different
I mean you got Outlook I feel feel silly
telling you guys that you got to take
advantage of your opportunities but it's
kind of silly for me to say that but I
mean you know what next time they win
the World Cup in four years you're gonna
be you know I mean that's why you got to
go take your photograph when you get
there
now I feel bad what was your first
Shakima was your first year at the
Seahawks and being teammates with your
brother again like I mean one of the
world was that like for you
it was crazy for me I mean it felt like
it was just so real when it comes to us
building a field together us doing my
meetings and practice and studying
together because it's like you think
about this this dream that you just
haven't you as kids and you gotta go
through so much to accomplish it and
then we actually dennis is like he's
still dreaming but we in a moment where
we're staying together you paying bids
together and as always it's definitely
cheaper paying bills together meals
everything he gets annoying sometimes
but you know that doesn't change what do
you mean it gets annoying I mean
sometimes you can talk about you know
you might have them day what you just
tired and you just want to come in your
room and mess with you and I'm just
gonna watch Netflix I mean it's that
true she killed system I don't know I
feel like that's I supposed to be
reversed I feel like he kind of my room
and mess with me most of the time you
know right now he's doing his thing so
I'm just letting to go okay who pays the
bills no I know that but who's actually
opening up the envelopes and sitting
down and main about give somebody to
help yeah my mom man this you take care
everything so you say I just want y'all
to focus on football that's okay mom
this is great that I'm sitting now
sitting here with you guys I got kind of
a little bit of chills because I
remember there's so many with you she
came yeah I remember so many moments
being at the microphone when you video
comes back from the waiting reps room at
the combine we see you put up 20 and the
whole world was talking about that I
mean that's not an exaggeration I mean
that the whole world was talking about
that and then you back it up by running
what you run the next day at 4:38
that was unbelievable now she she killed
where were you during that whole
probably just sit and watching it on at
home on yeah so was that uh actually my
older brother house
my whole family there watching and I
remember we're just talking about what
we you know thought he was gonna run and
no one guessed for three don't one
guessed it we just knew it's gonna be
fast you know you know I remember
hearing someone say well we had you know
more four high four or five or six guy
and somebody ran for three I tweeted
soon as you're in it I said I guess
y'all was just a little tad bit off with
the time so I remember tweet man that's
we went crazy but you know I know one
just didn't expect that he did is I
could wave say he's going to he say he's
gonna run fast and he did it it was
amazing it really she came it was
amazing and how much did this play into
you performing well me seeing you the
night before and telling you how I was
gonna run my 40 how much did that
inspire you owe me so much this is a boy
he was we came in make sure you're
stretching it the monster hoses I was
like I got a same thing yes
I might keep my head in the game that's
right thank you that's all I was looking
for I looked in the book I didn't I
didn't see anything in there either not
you do you know the first time we met I
know we have but I don't I think I
remember when was this Shaquille o when
we came to Michigan Oh remember yes okay
upset okay I didn't want to say you want
to say okay no no no because I've seen a
picture I've seen his picture I was
looking at your helmet Knox like what oh
yeah yeah I said this is gonna come up
no here she will come up well and and I
will do my best to describe for the
radio audience I was the honorary
captain that day can you put it up on
the screen for the here we go now you
guys are all shaking hands and there I
am tapping shakeela on the shoulder and
Shakib just walked right by me here
comes the slow motion I am just a
shorter can somebody shake my hand
please
she came just like SIA and she killed a
thank you for just giving me a little
DAP just a little bit at the handshakes
I'm definitely glad I did I did not want
to be the one I've been seeing slow boys
walking away so yeah okay I did I mean
she keep putting me on the paint no mind
list this was I said guys him game faces
came oh okay
I didn't see eye to eye put blinders on
as I was walking and you know oh yeah
run it one more time there it is I'm
just for somebody now I'm on the outside
look it there you go thank you that's
all I wanted the ref shook your hand
honestly I would have shaken anybody Sam
but clearly a member of UCF one of the
famed Griffin brothers would have been
good so thank you she kill I've really
done I really wanted to but I feel she
came you and I have you know yeah we
formed a bond since then and again when
you showed up on the set at the NFL
Network the whole family how many how
many members of your family were there
that day when she team got drafted its
it looked like more out I will tell you
that baby like 15 it's me like 15 people
yeah I remember now
can you walk me through Shaquille the
moment that the phone rang so she came
know that he was being drafted by the
Seattle Seahawks so at this point he's
just watching the whole time and I guess
he's needed a break so he put his phone
down what's at the bathroom as soon as
he left I've seen it area code to
Seattle area calling us like what I said
no this can't be so I grabbed the phone
and I had to jump over my niece and my
nephew lemon floors relaxing let me jump
over them had to bust open the bathroom
doors let me just answer phone you got
it's a phone I said he's doing yeah ESPO
it was like what what I gave him the
phone he should have washed his hands we
can go back to that later
so you gotta answer it so he finally
answered it you know you got peak hair
on the other end you got John and
everybody and I don't think he even got
any worries actually yeah
I don't think I did a very short combo
yeah listen I'm sure they got a mother
I'm sure I'm sure got emotional I got a
you know we cuz we were wondering when
this was going to happen if but the fact
that it did happen and it was your
brother's team she came to get you into
the NFL I mean that that is I mean it's
stuff of a book right here inseparable
we're books are sold movie TV I mean
this that's what this is right totally
and so um did you not know she killed
that the Seahawks were doing so they tip
you off at all no no there was no tip
but I knew they had you know no love and
respect you know for my brother and you
know just going and watching him the way
he carried himself everything they have
done you know so that was the best part
about it I just remember you know before
right before the draft was about to
start you know John those guys you know
Camus I spoke to me and she's like just
tell your brother that we love him a lot
and just enjoy this moment you know this
something that doesn't happen twice you
know enjoy your time with your family
and just know we love him over here you
know just enjoy experience so it was no
tip it was nothing we you know he kept
it you know business casual so it was it
was just as surprising to see it happen
as it was him she came and she killed
Griffin here on the Rich Eisen show
together inseparable how family and
sacrifice forged a path to the NFL is
there book where books are sold she kill
you have blossomed into a terrific
corner in the National Football League
your thoughts
however on your work being instant
replay reviewable this year potentially
what do you think about the new twist if
you will that dpi and OPI by the way are
both reviewable this year actually I'm
actually pretty excited for that one you
are you know I'm actually pretty excited
for that one I feel like the games will
be a tad bit longer but I feel like it
was safe you know defense you know
speaking for the defense out of the ball
and you know defensive backs it was safe
you know a lot of issues that have come
up and you know it don't get me wrong it
has been really tough calls you know is
every call is not easy for
to be able to you know decide and now
that we get a chance to really slow it
down and kind of evaluate it now if I
was gonna help the game a lot more it's
a lot of games that we can go back in
and speak on that some people still may
seem like something should have been
called but now we get a chance to slow
it down actually get a look at it so I
feel like a lot of games would you know
go a little it's interesting cuz you
know your head coach would I think like
to do away with replay just say out all
of it so you're taking an opposite point
of view yeah because I maybe I'm
speaking mainly for my side no I know
you know because situation I don't mean
to make it like you know you're your
coaches one thing that's the other thing
at all I'm just saying that there's
obviously varying viewpoints and the
fact is well that you know you could
kind of call it on almost every play
yeah you know so you like the fact that
that microscope might be on you yeah as
you know because I feel like no just
relying on my technique I feel like I'm
playing the game pretty clean but I go
against receivers who kind of get away
with certain things and that happens but
um nowaday you know it could be a really
close game and you may need that replay
so I'm looking at it that way like I
said those replays could actually save a
game yeah and you could also by the way
if there's a flag thrown on you for
defensive pass interference for instance
and they look at their play again and
they see a receiver pushing off you they
could put a flag on the field for
offensive pass interference because
anything when you open replay anything
that's reviewable can be reviewed and
OPI is also reviewable it's going to be
knots it's more every one happening we
trying to figure everything out it's
gonna be a lot of college I know for
sure the first couple weeks is going to
be you know the first time I'm trying to
figure it out process yeah yeah no doubt
about that this is going to be different
and she came what are your goals for
this year I mean what do you what do you
every down are you gonna be laying every
down guy now pretty much is all we're
looking for here or for the most of all
I'm just looking
just be the best teammate um you know
just getting Chancellor the Rushmore
this year get a chance to kind of to
feel myself a little more I mean just
this past spring during our conditioning
period you know coach was really happy
with know how far I came and yes this
being able to come off the edge much
more able to make plays I just feel like
the coaches are putting me in places for
me to create more opportunities for
myself so I mean I'm so excited for the
season I'm so excited to see what's
gonna happen and whatever I can do I
just want to make plays for the Seahawks
how about Metcalfe huh talk about big
dude did you see um Pete Carroll take
his shirt off did you see the video did
you see that yeah I've seen it
hey Pete take your shirt off it's gone
muscle over there you know his people
really deaf you that's kind of you gotta
be coming out gone swole yeah think
about DK no more at the scene feels like
this is it this is crazy
yeah came you having all that muscle you
put Pete in front of a store like a
mannequin I had no idea I know and I
thought you wouldn't talk about somebody
who's just putting it out there yeah
Pete was yeah he said a them for yeah
that setting example right always
compete that's what he says right I
didn't stop and no you're not talking
about Metcalf you're talking about PT k
Metcalf is like you know the human
Batsuit right but peope with an exit
Pete like Batman or Robin I agree with
Pete been maybe in the Batman right okay
I totally understand that so what what
is uh what why did you guys decide to
undertake this book before I let you
guys go I feel like you know my telling
the story so many times you know it's
it's pretty much everywhere but I feel
like it's so much more to us besides you
know just what my brother's been through
away you know we've been through
together I feel like this book talks
more about you know family faith and
it's not just a football you know
telling book 8 it talks about you know
family and and moms and dad making
decisions at early age you know for him
and us it talks about you know growing
up making mistakes and people deserve in
second chances you know I felt like that
book it comes everything so it could get
pretty emotional you know you see the
cover you see a smiling but there's so
much more underneath just those smiles
because we actually been through things
you know we've seen a lot we've been
through a lot and now you get a chance
to actually go in to look deeper and see
how I was raised and see the decision
that was made that helped us get to
where we are today
and you know the best part about it you
know we had we didn't make mistakes but
we learned from it and we put you know
those things in the book so you can
really understand who we are and where
we come from and I fly that's the best
part is not just about football we want
to be able to reach you know a different
type of all that's not just you know
athletes and wanna be able to reach the
moms a dad the parents brothers sister
their love and it reached the people who
felt like they make mistakes and they
can't bounce back from it so we want to
be able to reach everybody so we don't
just inspire just one who try to inspire
a million in try to be able to relate to
everybody you guys are awesome
I mean seriously did the message that
you guys convey through family and
obviously football is it's really second
to none
it really is do people even consider you
an adaptive athlete anymore she came do
you think no I mean for the most part
just me just doing I'm doing just Signum
before anybody any and everybody um I
don't feel like a person who's just
definitely I just feel like an athlete
and I think for me is you know me being
able to carry myself that way it's gonna
show that anybody will feel like they're
our deaf athlete that eventually they
gonna want to just be seen as athletes
we all want to be seen as just athletes
and you know in our generation now as we
keep going
we just gotta just just keep motivating
keep pushing ourselves keep it coming up
the best us and eventually it's not it's
not gonna be just she came good friend
of every there's gonna be she came here
from the athlete well it's just great to
see you guys literally inseparable
that's name of your book despite the
arguments I guess over and interrupting
and Netflix by just yammering
you guys accusing each other of the
that I'll be honest it does seem like
you might be more guilty of it Shaquille
than than that thank you that said when
somebody extends their hand to you to
shake it you actually shake it
she came Griffin we'll just keep below
right by you there's video evidence
there right is there okay I feel like we
should hug it out like we should hug it
up just and shake it out well yeah we
could we could wreak to recreate that
Shakira and I are great we're cool right
I mean we've I mean we are cool after
the the combine in the draft and all
these guys together yeah we stretched
together we did do that actually one
point it's great to see you it's great
to see you guys handling your business
and handling your fame and handling your
family and handling everything just like
as great as you are so congrats on the
book and thanks for coming in here you
guys are welcome here any time tell Pete
I said hi tell Batman I said hi G on
Twitter and Instagram is that Shaquille
and Shekinah is at chicken Griffin on
Twitter with an underscore in between
the first and last name on Instagram and
check out inseparable in a book store
and we're all books are sold for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app